see for me when it comes to religion in
particular i would say up until just a
couple years ago i was such an adamant
atheist and i wouldn't say that i'm a
theist now at all i'm i just wouldn't
classify myself as either being pro or
against i'd say i'm undecided the reason
why i don't focus on the wrong is
because to people like me and and you
scientifically minded people it's fairly
obvious the wrong it's just so blatant i
find it much more interesting and
difficult to see well what is compatible
and what is correct from another point
of view
may also that
definitely knowing where one is wrong
even the nuances of incorrectness adds
to certain correctness like gives you
different points of view so let's i
understand that
you know speaking of what's wrong i'm
curious
let's imagine if
all properties are relative okay now is
the law that all properties are relative
a property can you be relational with
respect to the principle of relation
what does that even mean does that lie
outside
do you understand what i'm saying i know
this is extremely ill-defined
but i'm always interested in what
happens when a principle is applied to
itself
so even let's say bayesian reasoning
if you ask someone who says i'm a
bayesian reasoner okay so do you believe
anything with 100 certainty they may say
no like i'm a scientist so i doubt okay
do you doubt the principle of
bayesian reasoning even one even a
little even a time because as soon as
you open a sliver there then what
happens when you
well
you get what i'm saying
yes of course i get well what you're
saying um
[Music]
i think that one of the
interesting trends in contemporary
philosophy
it's
what it might be called
anti-foundationalism
it's not
a new idea there was
anti-foundationalism
in um
thinking in
in western and also in eastern
philosophy um
and this is idea that what does that
mean yeah it's the idea that you uh
you don't
need to hold
to
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
not only to absolute certainty but to
any
to anything definitive
is is sort of is a shift is idea of
shifting interest
from what we can say for sure what can
you say from final
to uh what we can say
um
interesting and and and and valuable
um
in fact this is
look uh kurt your your um
your series is about the theory of
everything
i don't think we need a theory of
everything
i i think we need good theories
the more coherent possible the more
uh useful possible more advanced
possible
like pragmatic
as soon as someone says use i think of
pragmatism like it's all a goal based
whether it's adaptive uh
well maybe it's pragmatic i don't know
it's a
pragmatism
philosophical current has as much more
um
i
i think that
what i like in science and in philosophy
it's the part of them that have this um
uh
this attitude
which is look we can learn it's it's
historically we know what we can learn
we can learn more and more and more but
it's not useful it's useful to ask
as best as we know today what is the
best organization we have of our
of of of the world and it's true that
there's a remarkable coherence in our
culture and our understanding of the
world
but asking what is the final
uh ingredient of the world what is the
final rules of thinking
what is the basic substance of
everything is just a bad it is a useless
question
that's my take
so can we live with uncertainty yes do
we have to take something as
uh
can we doubt our also our doubt sure we
can
it might be useful
you